So video is sponsored by helix.
Helix makes extremely comfortable and Walty mattresses
catered to whatever sleeping style you may have on their website.
You will find a two minute Wiz that will match you with the perfect
helix mattress for you
here
in a box when you open it.
Sorry, Julie. No on it.
Pick it up.
You can visit the link in the description or go to helix.com/smr.
To get up to $200 off your new mattress and two free pillows.
Thank you so much helix. And thank you guys for watching. Enjoy the video.
I looked up a S Mar farting, just to see.
Hi, welcome back. Certainly glad you could do it.
Yeah, SMR that's been around for a while.
Let's get a little bit on the knife. I must begin.
It. Places like pop culture and TV
is running down,
but Duke has transformed in recent years.
The dire media full of controversy, intimacy, innovation,
humor, and humanity.
This is spectrum artists.
We invited six artists to see the range of their beliefs
and experiences.
Hi guys, my name is April buckles, also known as April SCAs Martin YouTube.
I do fast aggressive. I'm just really weird.
I have two cats and that's about it.
Hello everybody. I am Rafi from Rappi dafis ASMR and uh,
I'm just excited to be here. Hey guys. It's bevy. Wait, can I restart?
Okay. Hey guys, it's Mark.
And I have three gaps. I'd like to add that.
I also have one guy.
Hello everybody. My name is GB.
I've been making ASR for four years and my channel is GB a SMR. Also,
I'm more of a dog person.
My channel is brutality. I enjoy it.
I have no pets. I want a dog.
I am ASMR glow and I'm a big fan of Jubilee.
I'm really excited. I don't have
a SMR. Is sexual
April strongly disagree, Rafi, strongly disagree.
Vivi disagree.
GB, strongly disagree.
Tala, strongly disagree, glow disagree.
ASR, autonomous sensory Meridian response is not sexual.
They did a study on it. People's heart rates, slow.
People are calmer when you are sexually aroused. It is the opposite.
Uh, the kind of intimate aspect of ASMR, the whispering,
and it's a very personal one-on-one type of content can sometimes be
mistaken for a sexual, uh, thing, right.
To compare it to is, um, when I was younger,
the first ever AMR experience I had,
I was like nine or 10.
And my history teacher was like trying to teach me how to do something.
And the sound of her clicking in the Sanford whispering, mainly had tingles.
I was like, okay, so how could that be sexual?
I like to compare it to like real life massages out of context. You're like,
I'm going to go into a dark room.
And a stranger is going to rub my body when something new,
like that comes up like ASMR. Nobody understands what it is. You're like,
I really like to listen to people, whispered into my ears. People are like,
well, it's gotta be a sex thing.
And also the point that there is going to be erotic ASR,
but that's kind of a no point too,
because there's going to be sexual anything because that's what we do.
It's just like Hollywood, you know, there's like movies.
And then there's like the sexual branch, which is like porn. Does that make the,
the normal movies sexual? No, it's so it's just the same with ASM art,
like sex in general as its own thing. There's nothing wrong with it.
Can you tell my childhood self that? I mean,
I've gotten a lot of this being the one that did your eating and stuff.
I loved mouth sounds and I was so fascinated with the 3d. Oh.
And I was so nervous before that. Cause I had thought about it,
but then I recognized that no matter what videos I was posting,
as long as my face was in there,
or I was in there in some capacity whispering or whatever,
there were going to be sexualized comments saying inappropriate things or
whatever. So I was like, you know what? I'm recognizing that.
So many people love these sounds too, and it's not sexual.
And if I could help them, I was like,
let's just do it and just kind of accepted it and I'm stoked about
it.
Yeah. And I think a lot of it too is just people, sexualizing women. Cause, uh,
I can't say that I get many, uh, sexual comments or in my,
in my comment section. Uh, but that's just because I'm a, you know, I'm a guy,
my friends and family think my job yeah.
Is weird. April strongly disagree. Rafi.
Strongly disagree, freebie.
Agree. GB, strongly disagree. But Tala agree.
Glo disagree.
It took a lot of time for people around me to understand it.
Like my parents, obviously they're from a different generation on top of that.
Anything that's ASMR because it's so new that how do you describe that to
someone when they try to watch my videos is just, uh,
me making sounds. But, um,
eventually I saw that it didn't actually matter that they understood what I was
doing. They would still support me in whatever I was doing because they saw it,
that it was important.
When I very first started.
ACMR when I hadn't shared with anyone when I was doing somehow my parents come
across my channel on their own. And I remember my mom and she was,
she literally cried and uh, you know, was very worried about what I was doing.
She completely didn't understand it, but over the years, it's, it's, uh,
they've seen what, you know, what it is. And now it's literally my,
like my dad shows my videos to absolutely everyone. He comes across.
It's probably a little embarrassing, but he's my biggest fan.
And my biggest supporter.
In the beginning, I had many interventions from my family saying like,
you need to stop. I don't know what you're doing. But over time, I think after,
especially I started showing them some of these comments, these emails,
these messages that I was getting from people that had PTSD, tinnitus,
they were war heroes. You know,
like it's just from all different walks of life personally thanking me for my
videos. And so my friends and family, I don't think still understand.
And they definitely think it's weird.
I think they respect it now because they recognize how passionate I am
about it and how, even though it doesn't really help them,
they can see how a SMR has affected and helped so many people.
My dad will reply to comments. My mom will reply to hate comments too.
My mom will delete them. Sometimes my mom checks in on me. She's like,
I saw that really mean comment. And you're saying, I'm so sorry. I was like,
mom, what comment? What are you talking about?
I think you've been scrolling for like, I'll tell him, I'm like,
you don't just stole it.
Some SMR grosses me out
April at CRI Rafi, disagree.
Somewhat agree. Somewhat disagree, somewhat disagree,
somewhat agree.
For the most part, I kind of enjoy a very broad range of ASMR.
I love the mukbang community. I like watching people.
What do you think about sexually SMR? Right?
I don't, I don't consume, uh, sexualized smarter. So maybe that,
yeah. It's almost like I.
It's so hard for me to be judgmental because like people just see something and
they're like ill and I'm like, just relax.
This is doing something for someone somewhere, somehow, whatever.
I get muck bugs. Even sexual ASMR. Yeah.
I'm not like a fan of sexual ASMR,
but it's not something that I'm going to watch.
Can I ask why does it make you feel uncomfortable? Does it make you, it's not,
it's just not like, um,
an effect that I'm trying to like get like watch ASMR for
relaxation,
but not like necessarily to get like aroused.
I would just like to clarify the reason I said this was because you hate my
finger flutters, toll lighter.
I just get very uncomfortable and I'll like click off of it. It's more, um, I,
this one lady was eating live squid, live animal.
But most of it, I think it's really cool. No judgment. Like do your thing.
I've come across type of ASMR. You know, she was in a dungeon.
She had the whips and Oh, you sit down right here. You've been so bad.
Stabbing you to death. AMR is Angelica's videos.
She's like, I'm your period. And she's like, that you're not pregnant.
So she's like taking eggs and like squishing them.
There is a couple of role-plays that like,
they're like roleplays or like that gives me tingles.
I can't do it because it just takes me back to high school. And I'm just like,
I'm trying to relax here. I don't mean to have like,
it gives me tingles because I've been watching ASMR for so long that like the
hello, sweetie. Everything's going to be fine. I'm like, I've seen it.
I've seen it. I've seen it.
So they're like sitting her ugly down and let me do your makeup
though. One time I did look up, okay, this was my fault because I just,
I needed to know. I was curious.
I looked up a S Mar farting. See,
I clicked on this guy who had like a jar of jam. And it was just like,
I wish you didn't say it. I wish he didn't say it. I looked this up afterwards.
I hope you guys know that.
I've had to protect myself from some of my viewers.
April agree. Rafi, somewhat agree.
Strongly agree. GB, strongly agree, somewhat agree.
And Glo strongly agree. I need to preface this with that.
99% of my community are angels. And I love them. Like,
it really upsets me that I can't share everything because of the small
minority that lately, legitimately, they want to hurt you. I wanted to meet ups.
I want to vlog. And I cannot. And it frustrates me so much the same.
Yeah. People were sharing my app. My, well, it wasn't even my address.
It was my parents' address around online. And um, just, uh,
people adding me on my personal Facebook. And uh, it's just,
it feels really invasive and makes me worry. Right?
Cause it's not even my interests floating around there. It's like,
if there's someone who wanted to do harm to my parents and I'm sure, you know,
this is something that people tend to target.
I think women more on YouTube than, than guys.
So I don't see it as much and I've never felt unsafe.
So I have a lot of respect for you, ladies that you put yourselves out there.
I will say I've talked to like, uh, I have like guy gamer, friends, YouTubers,
and they still experience it. I had a, actually a recent experience.
I recently posted my address by mistake on Instagram.
And it had already had like over 2000 likes,
like I had messed up things that have been coming to my house.
And like Rafi said, it's not my house right now. It's my parent's house.
It's just something, some of the things that you don't, I guess expect,
you don't think to look out for things like that.
And I've always came from like a lifestyle where like you can just post
whatever. And only people that are going to see is people in the city.
And I've lived in a very small town. So like everybody know me already.
So what does it matter?
There is a couple few that just love to mess around and they love to, uh,
do what they do. Yeah. I think some people don't even recognize like, Oh,
people might see me outside and they're like, Oh my gosh, this is crazy. Like,
can I take a picture and all that? And then I kind of have to say like,
please don't post where like where we are or whatever,
because I've had like very disturbed people that have been
stalking me and I've had to like ramp up my home security.
I've gone and talked to the police. So they know where I am.
Like I've gone to certain extents to make sure that I am
protected. I don't know. I don't know. Yeah.
Maybe we're more of a target and then an AMR because it's more
personal, it's more intimate.
I've gotten people who kind of put together something in their head and they
think that we're dating.
And so they got really upset that I got a boyfriend and then there's all of
this, you know, that comes from that. Um, for me.
Being black in general, in the world,
we're dealing with a lot of racism throughout my YouTube career.
I've dealt with a lot of using the N word and then going off saying like how I
want you to die. I want you, you're just ugly. You're this, you're this like,
it's very prominent. Um,
as a black ASM artist to get those types of comments.
I'm, I'm kind of in the same spot where I'm Jewish. So I do,
I do read the same kind of, uh, atrocities.
It's getting to the point where you're, you're scared to put yourself out there.
I literally stopped taking Instagram pictures like outside, because I'm like,
what if the background, you know, like what if they recognize it or whatever,
like this, this green tree, maybe they're going to like pinpoint that.
It's like where I am literally they would,
I find myself really like paying attention to every little detail of what I do
in a day to like,
make sure that I'm not putting my information out there and like,
just like protecting my life. It's just, it becomes insane. The SMR.
Unity, lacks diversity, April.
I'm going to say agree. Roughly.
Agree, privy, agree, somewhat agree.
Batalla agree. And Glo somewhat agree. I'll tell you why.
I said somewhat it's because I watch a lot of ASM artists and there are
so many amazing small creators, every country,
every like age, like you can see, you can find, you can find it now,
but it's really hard to find what is pushed.
At the top on YouTube,
especially the top of the isomer community is disturbingly. Non-diverse.
One of the things too is we don't see a lot of Malay,
smartest kind of grow too big, you know,
to the big channel statuses AMR is a kind of an intimate thing for a lot of
people. And some people feel kind of more uncomfortable with, uh,
having that experience with a male. Yeah.
That's so true. But when I saw like Rafi and I got tangled from,
and he just looks like,
I just want to hug you look like you're such like a huggable person.
He had a cat on his mattress and his helix sponsor. And I was like.
Thank you.
Um, I feel that, um, as a black person,
the algorithm of YouTube or just algorithm in life, it's always white.
And then it just trickles down from there. You know,
if I search into to YouTube,
like the first thing you see is just like the white ASM artists.
And I can speak from experience when I have these blue contacts in.
And when I have my hair straightened,
I get way more views than when I had my hair natural with Brown eyes. Yeah.
It's not like they're doing it on purpose. Like, Oh,
I just want to watch a white person today. Or, you know,
I think it's more of just like,
they kind of unknowingly just choose what they're comfortable with.
And I feel like ASMR can be more diverse, but it's getting there though.
It's getting there.
SMR is my main source of income.
April Rafi, strongly agree. Freebie.
Agree. GB, strongly agree, strongly agree,
strongly agree. I entered the ASR space, like just the perfect time.
And when it made more sense for me to be filming a video than to sit at my
minimum wage job, I quit my job.
I feel like I have the freedom to be making as much content as I'd like for
people. YouTube, vicious,
kind of like a big old question where sometimes we don't really,
we have no contract. We have no nothing. It just is what it is.
Zero transparency as to what is, what is acceptable.
Yeah.
YouTube can be difficult if you put a sounds or wet or these certain
words, you can get monetized and I've dealt with that a lot.
Would they being your main income? You kind of struggle with flight. Okay.
So should I post this or should I like do something else?
Because what if it gives, do you mind to high? So you never know with YouTube,
it's so frustrating and they won't, they won't be transparent about that at all.
It's just been very up and down. Whether they like ASMR or not.
There was moments that I felt I was literally like shadow banned on YouTube
because, you know, I was the ear eating girl, but no matter what,
even from that point, it was like, I was, I uploaded a brushing my hair,
video demonetized, and I'm like messaging them.
And I'm getting so upset because like I was month to month and I'm like,
do I get to quit my job or not? Like, I'm, I'm in the middle here.
And I'm just getting so angry in emails.
Like you are messing with people's livelihoods,
not being transparent and not letting me know what is wrong with this.
I'm brushing my hair as ASM artists. We also deal with the,
like the ads. So, you know, when you watch a regular YouTube,
they have like 20 ads and we got to put like one because it's for relaxation and
they want to sleep so that people are still complaining. Why is your ad in here?
Like, okay, you can just like, let me come over here. So we deal with that too.
And I think the reason why I've now said, um,
agree is because the sponsors have like changed my life.
I stream on Twitch as well.
And I just had an amazing community that was supporting me that way with subs
and donors and stuff like that.
I was always making more from Twitch than I was YouTube.
And people would be so surprised with that with like how many subs I have and
how many views these videos are getting. But it's like,
I was getting nothing when it comes to money for those,
for those views and stuff. I think there's a lot of people, um,
especially subscribed,
especially who think that I'm rich and I own like this huge home and I don't,
you know, like I was able to quit my nine to five, but I still do. Like,
I work on sets like with like productions in the areas.
I still need that extra money. I'm sitting here like 22, 23 in college.
I really want to move out in order for me to move out.
I can't rely on YouTube right now. A lot of people ask me if, uh,
they should quit their job to do YouTube full-time and
you know,
like knowing all the highs and lows that we've been through on YouTube,
especially with ASMR, YouTube is such a risk. For example,
I don't imagine myself, um,
still being like the content creator that I am right now
in, uh, I don't know, in five years,
I imagine that people will have forgotten. I have an expiration date. Exactly.
Like younger people will, will come, will be more creative.
Your money, save your dad money. Like we will.
Globally disappear is just like,
it can be sometimes okay.
But it can also can be not. Okay. So it's a gamble.
SMR is therapy.
April strongly agree. Rafi agree, freebie,
somewhat agree. GB, somewhat agree.
Batalla somewhat agree and glow angry. But I think with this.
Is the word therapy,
like I I've never thought that ASMR is like a substitute for getting
therapy with a professional, but is it therapeutic? Yeah.
Absolutely strongly agree.
Don't underestimate real professional therapy.
I feel that some people look to ASMR to solve their problems.
And I've gotten comments sometimes where they're upset that this didn't work or
that didn't work. And it's like, I can't really be your therapist.
I'm just trying to relax you and calm you down. You know, I said,
strongly agree because at least for me,
I didn't really need AMR to aid emotional extent until this past
summer, when I had just got a breakup, it was six years. I was engaged.
It didn't work out. And I just did not want to wake up anymore.
And people used to request like do videos where you say everything's okay and I
never did it.
And now I understand why people just need to hear everything's going to be okay.
Like, you're fine. You're beautiful. You can wake up in the morning.
You can go eat.
You can go get dressed because I wasn't doing any of those things.
And I just really needed someone to wake me up and say, okay, April, get up,
get dressed, go eat your breakfast. It's going to be okay.
We also underestimate how important sleep is. Like it ruined my, my,
my life for many years.
I could not sleep because I was so anxious every single night. I just,
the fact that ASR was there for me.
Like I knew when I was making content that it had the potential to affect
people. But even, I didn't know that it would go this far. Yeah.
It's very humbling. Very, very humbling.
I could go forever on this subject.
I'm really pushing for research in the field of ASMR because I have a lot
of people on the autism spectrum in my community.
And one person told me once something that I will always remember,
autistic people, they crave hugs,
but they hate touch and proximity.
So ASMR is giving them some kind of like a compromise. And I've had all,
a lot of people with depression, PTSD, uh,
suicide problems. So many people who told me how ASMR impacted them.
And I think ACMR can help together.
Hand-in-hand with a lot of different therapies.
Something to consider as well as that for some people and especially younger
people, sometimes therapy, isn't something that's accessible to them. You know,
it is, it is the only form of therapy that they have access to.
And that's something that I didn't consider when I started my YouTube channel.
I just kind of started it for fun and to make fun sounds.
Cause I enjoyed watching sound assortments and stuff like that.
And then you slowly realize how many people you are impacting.
I think society nowadays,
we lose more and more touch with people. We lose more and more proximity,
especially doing now quarantine.
And I think a SMR sort of brings back like Phil's a little bit
of a void. I want to give everyone a hug.
Yeah. Wonderful. That's a wrap guys.
This has been super fun.
It's really fun. Thank you for putting it together. It's.
Probably you animal people. I want to show you my dog.
This is fun.